[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up ruff hello Walter hi how you
doing I'm well and you nice to have you
back thank you
can I ask it you can please open up for
us again with a word of Prayer yes
certainly
Heavenly Father once again we need
heavenly wisdom to make sense of the
conflicting information in the world out
there so I pray for your presence and
help us with our deliberations in Jesus
name Amen
amen last time we talked about all the
different aspects and things happening
in the world on the political front and
how it pertains to prophecy and you
mentioned the family the series on
Netflix now it was interesting there's a
article about the prayer breakfast
that's organized by the family now the
series spoke about that issue yes what
was interesting is sam brownback who is
chosen as a US ambassador at large for
the international religion religious
freedom alliance that was formed just
before Mike Pompeo already mentioned it
in July last year and now it was has
officially been formed and just that
evening before the prayer breakfast they
came together and 27 countries as
officially now joined this alliance what
is also interesting is that Brownback
went to Rome to have a meeting with the
Abrahamic faiths initiative they are a
coalition of Muslim Jewish and Christian
leaders now the Pope had a document that
is signed with the grand Imam the
document of the human fraternity and
this
new international religion freedom
ridges freedom Alliance underscore they
say they want to become the legs of this
of that document let the Pope signed
what is your thoughts on this well this
has a longer history even few months ago
they started an organization in the
United States to combat persecution on
the basis of religion and a number of
countries were to be economically
targeted in order to rectify some of
these issues a country that always comes
up in this kind of debate is China for
example where religious intolerance runs
quite high and then of course other
countries of as well that are very
closed books and the philosophy really
behind all of it is that most of the
conflicts in the world have a religious
basis if you think of Islamic terrorism
that has its basis in the jihad and the
parents notion that everybody who is not
of that religion is an infidel and
therefore you have to create a situation
where you have what is called religious
freedom but really means religious
tolerance so what they are aiming for in
the world is to have a system where
there is so-called total religious
freedom to worship according to your
conscience and all of these religions
must be side by side basically in
agreement that everybody has the right
to worship according to his conscience
which is a wonderful
right it sounds beautiful the trouble is
that once you start introducing that
then you have to keep the conflict at
the minimum what causes conflict hate
speech causes conflict now what can be
considered hate speech and what can be
considered as an agent of conflict and
what that is is of course to sell
somebody that you belong to the wrong
religion or your religion is false that
is attacking your human right to be
totally happy in your little world that
you are living in which includes your
religion so if we can create conflicts
I'm thinking in terms of regalian
dialectics now if we can create control
conflicts amongst all these so-called
areas of conflict and till you get to
the point where it becomes intolerable
then people will finally agree to say ok
let's not talk about it anymore
so you can do that on any level you can
do it on the race level you can play the
race card and have so much conflict
between the races that in the end you
say all right there is no more this race
and that race and the other race we are
all one and there is no difference in
the races which would be fine with me I
wouldn't have a problem with that but
when it comes to religion it's a
different story because what if you have
a commission just like the jihadist
believed that they had a commission from
Allah to change all the infidels or the
non-believers into believers by whatever
means that was the mission and they were
called fundamentalists now a
fundamentalist is really somebody
believes the literal teaching of the
word Bible that is actually what a
fundamentalist is so how it has been
skewed is to say that the fundamentalist
is somebody who forcefully tries to
introduce his religion but that's not
the definition but that's what the world
thinks so now you have these various
groups and now you hammer the group that
is causing this problem and you have all
of this turmoil and all of these wars
and finally the people are so shattered
that they come to the point where they
say enough we will all live side by side
or else we don't live at all yeah okay
now what if the Christian group then
eventually says this is what you have to
believe there is no other way to be
saved than this one particular way
there's no other name under heaven and
earth whereby you can be saved except
the name Christ Jesus now that could be
considered an affront to any of the
other religions or will be considered an
affront absolutely
so religious freedom in the sense of
living side by side in a conflict-free
environment must necessarily also then
curtail your freedom of speech in terms
of what you believe is present lysing
you're not allowed to tell others as to
what you can do so there are certain
legislations which have already been
introduced for example in Russia you
know you may not have a house church
which preaches certain things the only
place where you may live out your
religion according to the law is within
your house of worship in other words in
the church there you may speak what your
church believes
but if you belong to another church they
in that church you may speak what you
may believe but you may not tell others
outside of that context what you believe
because then you are creating conflict
you know so that's where we're heading
right what's interesting is that the
Pope recently said that you're not
actually allowed own shouldn't
evangelize yes no you shouldn't you
should just accept somebody where he is
and you are so this the whole what
you've been saying now he already also
confirmed from the Roman Catholicism
side and now they've started firstly
they were targeting those that were
deliberately persecuting ideologies of
whatever nature that were contrary to
the accepted now China the great example
in China says all religions may exist
provided that they do not contradict the
great Communist agenda and it may not
take reverence away from the communist
regime and so they started again mainly
with the Muslims and so many Muslims
were rounded up in in China and they
were put into concentration camps which
the Chinese denied they said they
weren't concentration camps they were re
indications reeducation camps and so
there was the sympathy that put up for
this religious intolerance and there
were issues of the beards for example
Chinese Muslims are generally beardless
because that is associated with their
religion and they're saying it's not
because of pressure because of this that
the other but obviously it is right and
then of course the Christians
are terribly targeted and it's almost
like in the days of the totalitarian
regimes in Europe where they were spies
everywhere you couldn't speak you were
arrested
if you said certain issues and many
people have been arrested you've got
information yeah it's so bad in China
that even there's recently been a pastor
and a few other of the congregation that
were erased it and the pastor got five
years imprisonment just for handing out
books on and sermons to his own
congregation evangelism material yes so
that's actually how bad it is at this
stage in China okay so now let's have a
look at this scenario the world cannot
have peace unless all of these religions
come and sit side by side so which which
ones are the most intolerable tolerant
as we said China China China or than
many of the Muslim countries also North
Korea as you mentioned is not open to
other religions and then you have many
Muslim countries and Africa is Nigeria
for instance yes and African countries
and and it's interesting that some of
these Muslim countries are now openly
advocating for the Staller ins yes and
the Pope was as you know the one who
signed the document with one of the
chief Imams yes and decided that they
were going to walk this road of
fraternity to work together just on a
side note it's interesting that that
document is also for re-education it's
also for re-education and in May they're
going to have the discussion on how to
re-educate the world and the youth right
and everybody is summoned concert invite
us because it's they've actually been
summoned correct and
normally the people the person that
summons is the one that leads out right
absolutely so all of this is coming
together so which countries must still
open the doors Saudi Arabia is a very
closed shop and that situation has to
change and is changing apparently I see
that it's not one of the seven countries
that have signed that they will work
together for religious tolerance it's
early days it's early days yes so when
did you started over 60 and right now
it's 27 countries and of course for all
the country it overnight just before
they had the get-together it was 17
countries and that night became 27 so it
can escalate very quickly correct so
these countries love to open their doors
and Pakistan and all of these that have
a very closed system of intolerance you
know even countries like Egypt there are
many people that are in jails there
because of well many issues journalism
religions you name it and this equality
has to come into the world now how do
you open those doors how do you get a
regime that is very closed to start
opening its doors well if the populace
can become aroused if they can feel
dissatisfied with their situation and
with their treatment if they start
feeling that their their freedoms have
been taken away to the extent that they
cannot live out what their ideology
demands then that can create change now
where did we see this in China
well Hong Kong you know you had massive
riots over many many months
in in Hong Kong because they don't want
this oppressive top-down structure that
you have in China China yes and then you
have your your other so-called countries
that are supposed to be part of China
like Taiwan for example and and now
there is the coronavirus interesting and
I find this coronavirus very fascinating
because number one it exposes a weakness
an authoritarian regime that is
curtailing the virus by isolating it yes
but by isolating it you are stopping the
movement of millions of people
you're not only stopping the movement of
millions of people you are stopping the
movements of millions and millions and
millions of dollars of merchandise yeah
so this does not affect people only it
affects the entire economy
it affects imports and the way in which
the government in its in its stance is
treating the people is leading to
dissatisfaction yeah I don't know how
many videos I've received of incredibly
upset Chinese people as to their
freedoms having been taken away
they are strangled they cannot live
under those circumstances anymore and
this is causing tremendous pressure and
I'm wondering if this is part of the
agenda or not I don't want to be
disabled the conspiracist although I
think it's a little bit late well but
you don't have to be labeled want to be
thinking this because there's also an
article now way
ina is blaming the u.s. for the
coronavirus yes it's been a lot of other
speculations as well this the Chinese
have denied that it is a human made yeah
now if they deny that it is human made
why are they blaming the United States
you know and there's so many articles
coming out that you showed me the
Asterix and Obelix
yes that had an antagonist that they had
to come a mask and one in 2017 they
brought out a cartoon as it were of the
games and you had the great leader
Caesar
yes pronouncing the games open and the
great hero supposedly was from Rome and
his name was coronavirus and that was in
2013 when there was no talking about any
of these things right coronavirus and
it's interesting that in his chariot he
had a sidekick right was also helping
with the reins etc and this named
person's name was basileus now but Silas
is bacteria right or virus or whatever
so it's fascinating that they have these
things and to me personally the fact
that he was the champion of Rome is is
slightly more than interesting that day
although I don't want to go into
conspiracies oh yeah I sometimes think
history is planned in advance once well
they do say all roads lead to Rome so
maybe all other things also lead back to
Rome yes because it seems that
everything ends up in Rome eventually
and all these leaders are going to go to
Rome but that's what's interesting for
me all of this that you can talk about
if it's the politics in America the
Democrats the Republicans if it's a
coronavirus if you if you really dig
deep
always get back to some room some Roman
influence Roman influence you know what
I think it is my personal opinion that
it is a lot of hype to create the
channeling of thinking you know if you
isolate it to a close chopped country
somewhere China it doesn't affect you
and me directly it's something that's
happening over there right but the fear
mongering
oh it's spreading in the world and
people are staying on ships and they
can't get off the ships and people are
dying there are hundreds of thousands I
read some percentages that the death
rate from the coronavirus is around 2.3
percent naturally now without any
treatment
okay so 2.3 percent and the death rate
on a normal flu is much lower than that
but because a normal flu hits the entire
world the death rate is from a normal
flu very much higher because of the
number of people involved then in the
case of the corona virus so it is
killing far fewer people than the normal
flu generally speaking at this stage it
can also come to an abrupt end and then
that fear will be away but what if what
is the the backlash the economy has
received a knock exports have received
in our for example the farmers in all
these quarantined areas and in these
cities that have been closed you have
these massive chicken farms for example
now they're sitting with all these
chickens what are they going to do with
them they can't export them because the
trucks and the trains that come and take
these things away are no longer allowed
to do this so the only thing they can do
is to kill them all yes so they're
slaughtering millions and millions and
millions of animals without the means of
creating an
which is sustainable in other words
they're saying there will be massive
food shortages and because of the export
market that will ripple over to the
entire world and I find it fascinating
that not only were there predictions
regarding this coronavirus supposedly
scientists wrote books many years ago
predicting that this would happen and
there were even predictions around about
the date which is 2020 that is just one
side of the issue the other issue is the
response of the governments I find it
fascinating that in the United States
the media is saying widely some in the
media are saying that this thing is
blown out of all proportions because
basically you most of the people who can
get over the virus by being at home and
recovering by themselves and far more
people die as we've already discussed
with the normal flu and why is there
such a dramatic response and the right
is blaming the left for alarmist
attitudes and what is even more
interesting to me is the response of
Italy now for example quarantine iing 16
million people closing of cities closing
of wealthy industrial or not the
industrial the economic hub of the world
Milan and Venice and other areas and
telling them that they may only shop in
the malls this is very strange they may
only shop in the malls in the week but
not over the weekends yes and then only
up until 6:00 and not after 6:00 now
that is very strange does this virus
only attack after 6 o'clock in the
afternoon and then
on weekends or is this perhaps a
lockdown strategy one one doesn't want
to go into speculations and conspiracy
theories but be that as it may the Bible
tells us there will come a time when you
will not be able to buy or sell now that
may not be just because you don't have
money to buy and sell or because your
bank account has been frozen it could be
because the shelves are empty the cities
are a hotbed of everything that is evil
and as it was in the days of Noah so
shall it be at the coming of the Son of
Man and we have examples of what
happened to cities like Sodom and
Gomorrah and the Bible says that the
earth will wear out like a garment and
the inhabitants will die like flies and
it is so easy to quarantine someone in a
city if you take the cities of the world
you just cut off the main routes and
within minutes there is a lockdown and
you will not be able to buy and sell and
you will be controlled completely by the
government now what is also fascinating
they were saying there wasn't much of a
patrol in these lockdowns now what do
the authorities do to enforce such a
lockdown oh the authorities or those
responsible for enforcing it are they
immune to the virus Oh does a plastic
jacket protect them from the virus and
no one else yeah so there are a couple
of things there which just do not quite
ring true nevertheless whether it is
real or perceived is irrelevant what is
the consequence and do we see the
biblical events unfolding
and I believe we are hmm is this
foreigner or a taste for a future
happening well if you look where it
begins in China and then it moved to
Iran it's interesting to me that both
those countries are not very
communicative when it comes to what's
happening and then it moved to Europe
and then Italy is the hardest hit and
there are a couple of cases in the
United States and South America's had
its first case and South Africa has had
his first case and then the wife of the
person who had it in South Africa also
got it and it's interesting that even
some of the politicians have been in
contact like some of the American con
politicians and they are in self
quarantine so yes this could be a
universal truth or it could be a reality
time will tell so a local problem in our
modern world is no longer a single
problem becomes an international problem
and so if you have all of these factors
put together and people are becoming
dissatisfied and they start opening up
now doesn't the Bible say that the
gospel has to go into all the world yes
now can a virus open a door for the
gospel yes yes yes enough
dissatisfaction it can open the door for
the gospel so the virus in that sense
could be divine or of divine origin
let's put it that way it could also be a
planned strategy mm-hmm it doesn't
matter in terms of prophecy who did it
doesn't really matter what does matter
is what is the outcome yes will this
open the doors because people realize
that they they cannot live in isolation
anymore because the world is
isolated place and if you want to be
part of that international community
then as those 27 countries which will
become 30 and 40 and 50 and a hundred
and a hundred and ninety until all the
countries or Breezer will become so much
that the rest of the world capitulate
then they will say okay we will not be
so restrictive we will not be so
restrictive in terms of religion but we
have to have certain rules and
guidelines now where are they building
the structure where
in the United Arab Emirates the
Abrahamic faiths Alliance that is what
sam brownback go into the throat
they are building now a synagogue and
mosque and a church next to each other
right on the same comp right and the
same complex they both so and they've
got a communal garden in the middle
aha so the garden is the common ground
their common ground surveys worship and
their own styles but they came together
and the fringe is social and social and
fraternity now that is where I believe
all of this is heading and in order to
make it fit into a short time frame you
have to have magnitudes of calamities so
the more the calamities increase the
more the the pressure increase to
introduce these things and because we're
all interconnected and all need to work
together on these issues eventually they
will say enough already
peace and goodwill to all men
peace peace we will live side by side we
will not attack each other anymore you
can believe what you believe as long as
your belief does not interfere with this
common good of fraternity and there goes
the gospel Commission and if you dare to
continue with your gospel Commission
eventually you will become the enemy
that interferes with an accepted norm
that has become central to the peace
initiative of the world the word is
peace peace peace and then sudden
destruction sudden destruction I believe
that these are vehicles to bring about a
world order that will satisfy the
worship goals of the arch enemy
mmm and exclude Jesus Christ as the sole
savior of the world
one more point before we close off today
climate change and the coronavirus I
find that even astounding when they
speak about the coronavirus and the
reasons why these epidemics are
surfacing and why we have you know more
zoonotic diseases and all of these
things they've always linked it to
climate change and that is to me a most
fascinating things of the corona virus
or any virus is linked to climate change
then there are articles where they link
it to human poverty yes the poor now
fascinating to me is that the poorest
countries in the world don't have the
coronavirus but the others do but there
is a link of course and it must be
climate change because climate change
and poverty together creates this
feeding ground for disease so whatever
there is whether it is if I'm being
sarcastic now a soup kitchen or a virus
so they will somehow link it to climate
change you know after all you have to
heat soup with something and that must
change their climate and it is so
ridiculous but nevertheless it feeds
into that human fear you have to have
the fear factor what is climate change
it's got to do with religion absolutely
nothing right but if you could reduce
the emissions by cutting down on
industry one day of a week wouldn't that
have a wonderful impact on climate
change and what if you could link that
to a religious day of celebration
contrary to what the Bible says
everything can be linked
back to religion no and if we look at
humanity and the history of humanity
conflicts all the bloodshed that has
taken place in the world in the end you
link it back to religion thank you also
I think what an insightful discussion we
will be back next time with a new
episode and new discussions on what's
happening in the world thank you
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time